okay our next speaker is yah alkali and
she will talk about cryptography
resilient to physical attacks
great music okay so a hi everybody hey
imma alkali and I'm a researcher here in
the lab and my main focus and researches
on cryptography and that's what I want
to tell you about today cryptography
that's resilient against physical
attacks which has been kind of one of
the main focus of my research in the
last three years or so pretty much
whenever i do when i joined the lab so
okay let me start with telling you about
kind of the wonderful world of
cryptography so actually let me say this
introduction is an introduction which
was made by buzz Barack and I really
like it so I'm borrowing it a ok so the
wonderful world of cryptography some
cryptographer I love cryptography and
let me convince you that you know you
should love it too and we've made a lot
a lot of progress or a lot of progress
has been made probably in the last 35
years or so so by now we know how to do
you know secure encryption and secure
authentication we know how to do public
key cryptography which is really
surprising it essentially says that to
people when they want to do to encrypt
messages to one another they don't need
to meet and decide on a secret key but
rather if I want people to encrypt
message to me I'll generate a secret key
on my own and I give I'll give everybody
my public key it was a concept that was
put forth by dephine Hellman in the late
70s very beautiful zero knowledge proofs
which are very surprising current kind
of paradoxical which essentially say
that you can prove things without giving
any information about why about why the
theorem is correct this was Norton's put
forth by Chevy goal vs evo me Carly and
rock off Thank You severe good thing
here and that many many others secure
multi-party computation identity based
encryption there's many many many
cryptographic schemes task that we know
how to do today so really you know the
situation route ography is fantastic so
let me just you know I don't want to
mislead you we didn't solve all the
problems in the universe in cryptography
there so I still need my job so for
example there still some open
the area there's the problem of software
Fisk Asian which is still wide open we
don't know how to do and I've been kind
of obsessed with this one and even the
problem that we have solved we haven't
told them completely so there's still
you know this is assuming some of them
assume that we don't know we don't have
quantum computers and if quantum
computers come about then they make
break others assumes a mathematical
assumption and if some mathematical
breakthroughs come about again they can
break I not to mention efficiency but
the point I want to make is that we made
a lot of progress and things are looking
great in cryptography let me contrast
that with kind of you know the ugly
world of security I hope I'm not
insulting anybody but even though
cryptography made so much progress still
somehow in real world things are getting
broken over and over again and we
haven't even solved the very basic
problem of secure communication okay and
in some sense were much worse today than
we were let's say 20 years ago because
the hackers and our attackers are
becoming much more sophisticated and we
hear about all these stories over and
over again about things being hacked
about security broken and so on so my
goal or our goal I think it's a
community and a lot of us who have been
invested in this is trying to bridge
this gap so in order to bridge this gap
we need to understand why is there a gap
so let me give you some reasons okay so
the first reason is you know let's face
it security is annoying okay nobody you
know when i'm asked every three months
you know renew my password i'm so
annoyed I just want to do 1111 so you
know if we don't have security you know
things will be broken okay so that's one
reason then there's another reason that
the human there are users a human they
make mistakes not only them actually the
designer is a human they also make
mistakes so there's sometimes bugs in
our program so when we prove security
its assuming everything is correct but
actually there may be bugs and hence
security does not hold any more and then
there's what's called physical attacks
and that's what I want to talk about
today that's part what I've been kind of
obsessed with in the last few years I've
also done some research I've been kind
of interesting the problem of
constructing alderman algorithms that
are robust to bugs in them but I'm not
going to mention that today so I want to
focus on the problem of constructing
cryptographic schemes they're resilient
physical attacks
so what do I mean by physical attacks so
in in the theoretical world of
cryptography traditionally it was
assumed that our computer is secure it
sits in some kind of a safe okay there's
a secret key there which is completely
hidden it was randomly chosen it's
completely hidden from the diversity
however in real life in reality actually
that attackers they have several
physical means by with the attacker
systems and here are just some example
so for example there's what's called
climbing attack we're actually kind the
time it takes you to the computation and
that's based on the time let's say that
it takes to produce a signature you want
information about the secret key that's
being used or acoustic attack where you
listen and based on the noise that the
CPU makes you may gain information and
so on and so forth and there's also
what's called radiation attacks or in
particular microwave attack its name has
been used where attackers put smart card
inside a microwave and what happened
this rate the radiation cause mutation
in the secret key and they use this
tempering to break the systems so
there's all these physical attacks very
broadly speaking they can be partitioned
to two groups leakage attacks where the
adversity do not change the secret key
but they just gain information about the
secret key and the other is tampering
attacks which include the micro double
radiation attacks with adverse we
actually tampered with the secret key so
I think the goal are one of the goals of
the theoretical cryptographers is the
design scheme that withstand such
attacks so let me there are actually has
been a lot of work in this area very
recently in particular and the area of
leakages in cryptography let me just
mention a few results and this is a
subset if I had longer side put more
note that almost everything starts from
like 2009 so the last years there's been
a really large kind of big leakage boom
in that community where people are
really invested in trying to to come up
with scheme that resilient to leakage
okay also in the regime of Tam personal
cryptography progress has been made not
as much unfortunately not because we're
not interested but because it may be
harder a problem so there's still some
more room for
there but let me explain to you one
thing that for example we can do okay so
let me give you kind of example so we
have like the encryption scheme or
signature scheme that resilient against
the following adversary okay so we can
we can resist ourselves we can be sure
that we're secure get the following
adverse way so here's an adversary he
has a smart card the secret key is
sitting there and he tries to learn the
secret key he wants to break the system
okay what can he do so first thing
that's the public key okay let's say
there's a public here so she ate it with
it then he can ask for a leakage where
you know he can time you can use
acoustic attack he's trying to attack
somehow and he gets information about
the secret key then he made tamper with
the secret key may put in the microwave
and as a result of secret key that
convert is gonna convert to it's gonna
be mutated and then you can leak again
and get leakage and you know if let's
say it's a signing card he can ask for a
signature and the signature will come
out and so on and so forth and the gold
say even against such adversary we're
still secure okay so he still cannot
break the system okay at this point you
guys should be very suspicious and say
you know what forget about tampering
just leakage whatever meany can leak
over and over again here I'm here's what
I'm gonna drum anniversary I'm gonna
leak as for the first bit ly scat for
the second bid the third and so on
eventual get the secret key so how can
you be secure against continue a leakage
so it even though you may think it's
impossible let me show you how it is
possible so you need to slightly think
outside the box you know and and let me
show you kind of one technique that we
use in this area to make to get past
positive results so the idea is to
update the secret key so what do we mean
there's a secret key here that Bruce Lee
may get leakage but what we'll do I have
like one more minute right they told me
I can get one yeah yeah okay so way so
what were ya know I'm finished a second
okay so then that security can be up
that what we're gonna we're gonna update
the secret key in each time period so
the leakage she gets are gonna be
respect to different secret keys but the
main point is that the public key should
remain the same so nobody in the world
know that I'm actually updating my
secret key and B and becoming secure
against these leakage attacks these are
done in my in the computers Valley
without the outside we're
noticing and as long as the leakage in
his time period is bounded we can prove
that this gives our secure so that just
one glimpse of type of technique we use
okay thank you good thank you yeah I'm
sure there many questions and we have
still a little bit of time so for one or
two depending how fast you ask your
question cryptography is such a
beautiful beautiful theoretical subject
but I wonder if you could talk about the
distinction or the connection between
cryptography radical area and and
cryptography is something that that's
driven by the real world attacks or the
real world so okay so I think in general
cryptography is an area that's driven by
real world attacks I mean it's true that
it has fundamental very interesting
fundamental mathematics in it but what
drives the field is practice it's a
field that's driven by practice and
here's just an example that the
motivation of this research is applied
motivation at the end of the day what
we're doing is math it's true that there
are scheme that are more there are
people that work on more trying to just
improve cancer like really ship things
out the door and I think these
improvements have look often they have a
different flavor to them so it kind of I
think there's various levels to
cryptography you know some some aspects
of some people photography work on
negative results you know you can think
that's maybe very fundamental however
it's also related to practice so I think
it's a all of cryptography i think is
driven by practice but some things are
more kind of practice this minute as
opposed to a kind of maybe a little more
long-term but i think all photography's
between my practice Hey Thank You Jana
was a wonderful talk
ok